I see live right good afternoon and
welcome to this virtual meeting of
cabinet my name is Tony Jefferson and I
am chairman of this meeting you've been
provided with the council's etiquette
for virtual meetings in advance of this
meeting however to reiterate the main
points please ensure that your device is
fully charged all uncharged please mute
the microphone we're not speaking when
invited to address the committee please
ensure your microphone is switched on
which happens when you finished
addressing the committee please turn off
your microphone immediately
please ensure you've switched off Auto
silent any of the devices you have that
may interrupt the proceedings if any
member of ANCA and society problems
causing them to drop out of the virtual
meeting they should use best endeavours
to read you and as quickly as possible
should that member being able to rejoin
the meeting they will be deemed to have
left the meeting at that point and the
meeting will continue provided it
remains court committee members present
online with me at the following cabinet
members and I will invite them to
introduce themselves and please do a
call for me
Thank You chairman okay we have yourself
councillor Jefferson yes comes from
Jefferson present councillor Pemberton
yes councillor Pemberton present
how's la barca yes counselor Barca
present Carla Cargill counselor Cargill
present Kandahar VP counselor Harvey
present counselor Shinto counselor
Shenton present counsel our Andy Hawkins
counselor Wally Hawkins present we also
have and three observers with us so we
have that counselor Jeunet absolute you
know present
the kettle how'd the kettle present
councillor Richards councillor Richards
to present also present online with me
of the council's heads of service and
officers from democratic services and
policy teams and can I just check that
do they may need to introduce themselves
as well perhaps they can introduce
themselves if they need to address the
cabinet Thank You Ann the meeting is
being broadcast live if any councillor
wishes to speak on an item please could
you indicate this through the chat
function when cabinet members vote could
they please ensure that they identify
themselves and speak into the microphone
so that their vote is understood clearly
by other members of the committee and
also by those watching the webcast
members should respond for against or
abstain right we now move to the agenda
have we received any apologies Ann we've
received apologies from councillor Perry
thank you
agenda item 2 disclosures of interest
have we any disclosures of interest I'll
take that as a no agenda item 3 the
minutes of the previous meeting held on
the 9th of March does anyone have any
issues on the minutes I'll take that as
a no as well so we will take the minutes
as agreed without a roll call agenda
item for development requirements
supplementary planning document SPD
adoption of part 5 climate change
adaptation and mitigation
before I call on councillor Pemberton to
present the item and move to a
recommendation mr. perks can I just
please understand the lead
advice that was received regarding
supplementary planning documents yes
later on Toni perks just for indigestion
to the meeting on the deputy chief you
say it said um yes and the leaders just
asked me to summarize some of the
activity on the passages to report to
the cabinet today
the original draft that we put out with
the SPD did include requirements that
renewable technologies be included as
part sorts of proposals over 20 square
meters this received quite a lot of
comments during the consultation page of
the bill and as a result of it officers
withdrew or amended this to suit make a
recommendation rather than the
requirements this matter was discussed
with the opening scrutiny committee as
the the paper sort of passed through
that part of its journey and as a result
of discussions there officers have
sought legal advice on to sort of what
we can can't do in essence supplementary
planning documents must interpret
requirements of the develop development
plan documents that you can't in and of
itself create policy which is set out in
the report that we've taken counsels
advice on this and the advice that we've
received is the reports before you today
sets the limits and how far you can go
within the current policy framework the
matter of the policy framework can of
course be reviewed as part of the core
strategy which you're sort of planning
to sort of carry out next year but for
the time being this is as far as legally
we can take the requirements win to
require renewable technologies as part
of development I hope that's useful to
you thank you mr. perks mr. Pemberton do
you wish now to introduce the item
properly thank thank you leader yes the
item it is for a recommendation to
cancel that part 5 bracket climate
change adaptation and mitigation closed
bracket of the development requirements
supplementary plan documents be formally
adopted the background
- this is that whilst within the
existing course strategy and existing
SPD's a number of elements relating to
climate change are referenced following
on from the declaration of the climate
emergency by this Authority there is a
desire shared on all parts to ensure
that we meet our climate change
objectives and whilst the the gold
standard if you will in terms of trying
to achieve that through the planning
process can only be facilitated through
a review of and refresh of the core
strategy it was the it was the view of
the climate change panel and then
subsequently supported by cabinets that
this council adopted a supplementary
planning document to give us much
clarity to planning officers in
considering applications in terms of
meeting our climate change aspirations
within the confines of the current core
strategy this document was therefore
drawn up consulted upon and is now
before members of cabinets with a
recommendation that the document be
formally adopted I think that's probably
the long and the short of it I think I
have I think we have John cafard here as
well as Toni perks in terms of being
able to answering any technical
questions and I think I'll take any
questions as well but leave it just at
that for the moment Thank You councillor
Pemberton councillor Juna do you would
like to speak yes thank you very much
indeed
I'd like to thank the officers John
cafard and all of his team for all the
work that was put in on the SPD it is
very much appreciated I've had my
differences over the interpretation
but I do accept now that there is been
some legal advice the problem seems to
arisen because of guidance given to
counsels at the time of the last course
strategy and that has since been
clarified by the RTP I and others but it
was not in the last course strategy
therefore there does not seem to be the
hook that was required for us to bring
this into the SPD but so that is a
disappointment but that's something that
seems to be in history the about that
get the guidance when mr. pickels
rescinded the Merton agreement what I am
happy about very happy about is that
there is a lot more about energy
efficiency fabric first approach to
planning and given that the next core
strategy the review is going to be a
number of years ago in years away from
coming in I would like to make sure that
the politics and guidance on climate
change is moved and we can progress and
progress as far as we are able I have
actually written to the RTP I just to
get get background but it is it is the
case that it would it was the fact that
it was not in the last core strategy
that was the weakness and we just have
to accept that now but I do hope that we
will move forward as fast as possible
and that was on in what I'm referring to
was renewable energy so energy
efficiency transport biodiversity let's
move as fast as possible and then let's
get the renewable energy into the next
core strategy as quickly as we can Thank
You councillor Jim is councillor
Pemberton do you wish to respond yes yes
thank you
leader just to give the reassurance to
councillor Junod and to members of
cabinet the wider Council and then
anyone listening to these proceedings we
are where we are in terms of the core
strategy and there are limitations to
the SPD that does not in any way shape
or form diminished this cancel
ambition to move as swiftly as is
practicably possible and to take
advantage of any opportunities to move
on the issue of climate change so just
to reassure councilor Junod that
certainly from a policy perspective and
the leader also has the climate change
overarching responsibility we will be we
will not be backward z coming forwards
with opportunities for us to to move
quickly on this issue in relation to
every aspect as it related to to climate
change so yeah we're all on the same
page about that council agenda
Thank You councillor Pemberton I see no
one else indicating their wish to speak
so can I move to the recommendation on
page 7 that Council formally adopts part
5 climate change adaptation and
mitigation of the development
requirements supplementary planning
document and I can I call councilor
Pemberton do you wish to propose this
yes later I do wish to propose that the
formal adaptation of the supplementary
planning document do I have a seconder
please Thank You councillor centered in
that case we move to a vote and after
you wish to ensure that the vote goes
appropriately sorry by that I mean in
terms of us going
yes sorry for against our abstain for
the benefit of doubt yes leader okay if
I start with yourself counselor
Jefferson for funds or Pemberton for
councillor Barca or cancel Cargill
Council of the Harvey for
councillor Shenton for cancer really
Hawkins for anonymous leader Thank You
Ann moving on now to agenda item five
capital out turn 2019-20 and capital
slippage I invite councillor Harvey to
present this paper Thank You leader
councillor Trevor Harvey the purpose of
this paper is twofold first purpose is
to inform members of the amount of money
spent by the council on capital
expenditure items in the last accounting
period that is to the end of March 2020
this amounted to 1.75 billion pounds as
shown in the third line of table one
I draw attention to paragraph one point
five and the underlying details set out
in Appendix 1 for the year ended 31st
March 2020 these details confirm that
capital expenditure of slightly less
than two million pounds was made in the
last financial year once section 106
expenditure is included the second
purpose of the paper is to seek the
cabinet's agreement two amounts of the
capital expenditure that could not be
spent in 2019 20 to be carried forward
to be available for commitment in the
current financial year of 2020 21 these
are referred to as items of slippage and
they amount to 4.4 million pounds as
summarized in paragraph two point three
point one and accounted for by head of
the relevant functions in appendix three
brief details of the reasons supporting
significant items that are sought to be
carried forward are set out in
paragraphs two point one point one to
two point one point 10 there are various
reasons for each of the amount
requested to be carried forward which
I'm sure mr. Hill would be happy to
provide further explanation if required
given current practices I asked members
therefore to accept the recommendation
that the capital budget for 2022 beg
your pardon
20 20 21 be increased by four million
four hundred and twenty thousand seven
hundred and eleven pounds for the
reasons set out and as recommended in
the paper
Thank You councillor Harvey I see no
questions on the meeting chart in
essence you have proposed the
recommendation can I have a seconder
please counsel pemberton okay
councillor Shenton is seconded so has
councillor Pemberton in councillor
Barker so without further ado and can we
move to a vote yes leader we'll start
with yourself counselor Jefferson Oh
councillor Pemberton come to the car get
up councillor Harvey for catalyst change
them for council already Hawkins for
unanimous leader thank you now to agenda
item 6a draft revenue won't turn 2019-20
and once again image councillor Harvey
to present this item Thank You leader
the purpose of this paper is threefold
first to ask cabinet members to note the
draft financial results for last year
second to seek the cabinet's agreement
to the resultant variance being added to
the general fund reserves and third to
ask members of the cabinet to note the
amounts to be added to the council's
earmarked reserves
in relation to the first purpose the key
paragraph in the paper is paragraph one
point five point one this reports that
the council's net expenditure last year
was actually sixteen point two million
pounds because some items of expenditure
could not be undertaken during the year
as had been provided for in the approved
budget it's requested that the sum of
two point six six three million pounds
be set against the 2019-20 budget and
included in the earmarked reserves to
enable the items of expenditure to be
undertaken in the current year this
would result in an overspend of
ninety-one thousand pounds for the year
equivalent to less than half of one
percent of the lated latest estimated
spend for the year of eighteen point
seven eight 1 million pounds as shown in
Appendix two on page 41 table one on
page 34 and 35 sets out the amounts of
and the reasons for the various
variances the unfavorable variance is
totaled to just over 1 million pounds
and of this amount six hundred and six
thousand pounds is attributable to a
single source housing benefits that the
council administers on behalf of the
government on the basis of these results
and the proposed actions table 2 on page
36 sets out the basis of the council's
general revenue reserves at the end of
March 2020 of eight point nine million
pounds in round terms while table three
itemizes the intended earmarked reserved
setting out the reason for them and
totaling a further five point eight
billion pounds again in round terms it's
perhaps worth pointing out that assuming
members of the cabinet approve the
recommendations proposed this would be
the position as at the end of March
20:20 the current circumstances mean
that there will be a review of both
intended levels of capital expenditure
this year and a review of all earmarked
reserves as an element of the
discussions of the council's recovery
advisory group the process of adjustment
to the financial circumstances in which
the council now finds itself will result
in proposals that are intended to be put
to the full council in October 2020
subject to any questions members of the
cabinet many have I asked that the
recommendations set out on page 33 be
approved counselor Wireless Hagen do you
have a question yes I'm seeking some
clarification please regarding the
deficit in the housing benefit outcome
of well over half a million pounds
because these figures compared to aim at
revenues for homelessness and rough
sleepers are also alarming and then we
go back to earmark reserves again
exactly the same for homeless and rough
sleepers so under if somebody could
please explain something about this
members cabinet members will recall I've
already written an email about projected
costs of the imbiah accommodation for
the homeless by Christmas site I do seek
more clarity please on the housing
benefits out turn position Thank You mr.
here lose that one for you yes I can I
can certainly start to answer that one
and if we look at table 1 on page 34
you'll see that the housing benefit and
explanation there refers to three
different items does the it's a
combination of things there was a
significant level of
write-offs of 175,000 that was not just
the write offs Indian but there was a an
element of catching up with write-offs
we had an an annual audit last year that
recommended that we wrote off more of
those debts they
were as likely to be recovered and it
would be more prudent to write them off
which we have now done it doesn't mean
we don't keep a note of them and redress
them if the opportunity arises but we
have written American accounts in
addition as the cost of B&B
accommodation that's just over two
hundred thousand and we all are all
aware of the significant high level of
rents in the area and Housing Benefit on
4c doesn't cover the full cost and so we
have to bear the difference and finally
there's the when people transfer to
universal credit sometimes there's a
drag and we have to bear the cost of
that as well because the that those
individuals have to be funded for a
longer period and it's interesting that
during the Kovac crisis the government
has set its store out to certainly and
rough sleeping during the period and has
made its opinion clear that edge should
be ended for the foreseeable future and
they have undertaken to fund that and so
far they have there's more funding
available for those elements and so in
the new year you'll see when we come to
the report for the first few months of
2021 there is no overspend in that area
and it's a combination of two things one
is the government's drive to stop this
happening again and secondly it we have
addressed the budget obviously has
passed the budget process
mr. Platts some believe you want to have
some context yes thanks yeah I think
just to answer Sarah's question in real
terms people with housing benefit
overpayments or people with multiple
debts and when you come down to it the
council tax the ultimate sanction for
not paying your council to actually
committal to prison not that we ever get
that far if they've got rent arrears
then the ultimate sanction is eviction
and homelessness and for housing benefit
the ultimate sanction is a county court
judgment so those people who have
multiple debts tend to be concentrating
on the priority debts of the council
and the rent and the housing benefit is
always right down at the bottom of the
pile
Thank You mr. Platts councillor Whaley
hugging's are you happy with the
responses you've received I am of course
happy with responses that I've received
but I'm still alarmed by the figures
involved thank you understood right so
without I see no more questions so I've
moved to the recommendations on page 33
that were outlined by Chancellor Harvey
can I have a proposal and the seconder
for the recommendations on page 33
please proposed good so I have
councillor Pemberton second in the
proposal so and can we move to a vote
please yes please and we'll start with
yourself counselor Jefferson for
councillor Pemberton for councillor
Barker come to the cordial and sort of
Shenton for council really Hawkins Oh
unanimous leader thank you arm so we now
move to agenda item 7 which is capital
budget monetary and once again it's
councillor Harvey Thank You leader the
purpose of this paper is to keep members
informed of the progress made over the
first two months of the year in
undertaking the council's
intended level of capital expenditure
table one on page 45 demonstrates the
intention to undertake expenditure of
six point three million pounds this year
including section 106 projects taking
into account additional funds of seven
hundred and seventeen thousand pounds
budgeted for this
this will result in the balance of the
council's accumulated capital receipts
and grants being reduced over the year
from 6.4 million pounds to 780 mm
paragraph 1.5 indicates the capital
expenditure of seven hundred and eight
thousand pounds has either already been
undertaken or being committed to by the
end of May in the first two months of
the year therefore the sums spent or
committed amount to 12 point two percent
of this year's available budget of 5.8
million pounds appendix two on pages 55
to 59 provides summary information
concerning the various projects yet to
be funded as a result of section 106
agreements I would again like to draw
attention to a single element that is
the degree to which the amount of funds
allocated under Section o section 106
agreements relates to affordable housing
at present in round numbers 3.2 million
pounds of the four million pounds total
value for section 106 agreements in
other words more than eighty percent of
the amount available is earmarked in
relation to the provision of affordable
housing
I asked leader therefore that the
current position on capital expenditure
and income for the first two months to
the end of May 2020 is noted I have no
questions recorded on the chat function
I think you just proposed the
recommendation on page 45 councillor
Harvey can I have a second to place
hi councillor barker thank you can we go
to a can we have to vote on this one and
I think for the cut this report is just
for noting but for the the purpose of
this meeting if we run through and we
just ensure whether everybody is in
agreement grade do you want to run
through the names please um yeah so um
come so Jefferson for Chancellor
Pemberton before council abouhalkah
Oh Cargill or cancel a hockey for
Chancellor Shenton Paul Hunter Bailey
Hawkins Oh unanimous leader thank you
and so we move on to agenda item 8 which
is revenue budget monitoring and once
again this is councillor Harvey Thank
You leader the purpose of this report is
to inform the cabinet of the revenue
picture of the council's finances to the
end of May 2020 we'd like to begin by
asking members to turn to appendix 3 on
page 71 this shows that the net budget
to be financed by the council this year
is twenty point nine million pounds if
we now turn to appendix 2 on page 69 we
can see that the budget for the whole
year is for total expenditure of
thirty-one point nine million pounds and
total income from various sources of
eleven point two million pounds the
difference between these two numbers ie
thirty-one point nine and eleven point
two is twenty point seven million pounds
together with the net cost of the cost
of benefits of one hundred and eighty
six thousand pounds
this represents the total amount to be
funded from various sources ie twenty
point eight million pounds as set out in
the appendix in addition appendix two
also sets out that as a result of the
kovat 19 pandemic the council has
received grants from the government of
thirty seven point seven million pounds
of which thirty million pounds has been
distributed in ways consistent with the
government's intentions leaving a
balance of seven point seven million
pounds at the end of May turning to the
position at the end of period two we can
see that in round terms the council's
expenditure of 7.5 million pounds was
four million pounds less than budgeted
this reflects the decision not to make
an early payment of pension
contributions of this amount as had
previously been approved in the light of
our current very changed circumstances
the impact of kovat 19:00 pan pandemic
is similarly illustrated in the
shortfall against budgeted income to the
end of May of a million pounds
principally due to shortfalls in revenue
of 810 thousand pounds generated from
fees and charges principally five
hundred and twenty five thousand pounds
revenue lost from the district's car
parks the combination of these results
means that the net cost of services
provided in the first two months of the
year was double what had been budgeted
section three of the paper identifies
the principal items of variance from
their budgeted figures during April and
May whilst section four provides
estimates for the out turn for the full
year managers and heads of service are
to be commended in providing these
estimates there the time of probably the
greatest level of uncertainty
surrounding the fine-tuning that the
council's finances they have experienced
so far during their careers
subject to any questions members may
have I asked the report is therefore
received I see no question so can I have
a seconder for councillor Harvey's
proposal that they reportedly received
councillor targil thank you so comes
notarial seconds and could you take the
vote for us please yes leader comes with
Jefferson for Angela Pemberton for
Chancellor Parker or cancel a Cargill
councillor Harvey for Chancellor Shenton
for councillor any Hawkins
so unanimous leader Thank You Ann so
moving on now to agenda items 9 10 11
and 12 which had to be approved on block
this is to confirm the minutes of their
housing investment panel meeting held on
the 4th of March 2020 the strategic
policy advisory group meeting held on
20th of February 2020 the member
development working group meeting held
on the 11th of May 20 20 and
stratford-upon-avon markets for a
meeting held on the 4th of June
are there any abstentions I see norm are
is anyone voting against I see nobody
voted against in which case the minutes
are as received are noted
so agenda item 13 start time of meetings
does anyone wish to propose a start time
for the meeting
as there are non shall we continue with
the starts I'm a meeting to 3:30 I
haven't proposed it counselor Pemberton
and peers - yes
most people are coming in with 3:30 so
can we take a vote on the start time of
the meeting to be 3:30 I will propose it
can I have a second to place councilors
Shenton is seconded can we go for a vote
please on yes
starting with councillor Jefferson for
3:30
yes councillor Pemberton or council
Abarca Oh sounds like a girl Ella Harvey
for Chancellor Shenton for counsel
already Hawkins Oh unanimous leader
thank you
moving on we have three items version
business which are urgent in accordance
with the provisions of the of section
100 B bracket 4 of the Local Government
Act 1972
and have been agreed for consideration
at this meeting with the chairman of
William scrutiny so agenda item 50
reopening of the letter centers seeds
councillor wormy Huggins the council's
five letter centers were closed on the
20th of March 2024 and instructions the
report before you provides a brief
summary of the position with regards the
potential reopening of leisure centres
and associated implication the report
requires urgent consideration by the
cabinet's due to likelihood of
government allowing leisure centres to
reopen mid to late July 2020 and to
prevent the further loss of customers to
competitors if other fitness sites open
but stratford-on-avon district councils
do not I bring you
particular site please in the following
the following section the reduction of
local authority leisure provision will
without doubt effect certain groups more
than others
reducing accessibility to affordable
facilities and impacting on the
well-being and equality of our residents
additional questions and answers can be
sought
Julie Julie Lewis thank you thank you I
see a request from Telstra JUnit for an
update on the grade after the meeting
which Tony perch is happy to provide so
without further ado I see no further
questions
so the recommendation on page one
I assume you are proposing this item
councillor weary Hogan's proposed that
an additional payment up to ten thousand
pounds a month for the remaining eight
months of the financial year to Sports
and Leisure Management Limited so that
all registers can be reopened as soon as
legally allowed is approved in so doing
it is noted that Chappell name and
District Council will not receive a
management fee Sports and Leisure
Management Limited for the 2019 to 2020
finance all year thank you Thank You
councillor Willie Hogan's can I have a
seconder please councillor Pemberton
thank you can we move to a vote please
on one second I just need to correct the
recommendation pardon me a little
earlier earlier but actually is not
receive imagine fees the financial year
2021 another 2019 and 20 so I do
apologize for chairman if you could just
have a look with your forbearance which
is amend the recommendation without fail
abuse oh so did that amendment to the
recommendation and can we move to a vote
please on yes councillor Jefferson or
councillor Pemberton Oh counselor Baraka
Oh councillor Cargill councillor Harvey
for antlerless Jensen for and cancel a
rarely Hagen fork unanimously thank you
one so we move on now to agenda item 16
review of local government structures
Warwickshire and this one is down to me
the purpose of the report is to seek
formal endorsement to provide the
necessary decisions in relation to the
joint statement that was issued by the
leader of the council and the leader of
Warwick District Council on the 24th of
June that statement is being circulated
to all councillors in addition in terms
of this paper we have done a
presentation to I would say the vast
majority of councillors the
recommendation is on page 1 there are
recommendations to cabinet and then
subject to the agreement of those
recommendations to cabinet we are
recommending to council that their
principle of shared working with Warwick
District Council be confirmed as part of
the adopted policy framework and
agreements to be entered into with what
a District Council pursuant to section 1
1 3 of the Local Government Act 1972 and
all other enabling powers so that employ
ease can be placed at the disposal of
the other council as may be required
subject to the leader of the council
endorsing business cases for any social
services counselor Junod I see you wish
to comment just just say thank you for
keeping us updated up till now but it is
going to be absolutely essential on this
item that we are kept up to date all the
way through this process
this is not
something that we need to you know have
one group you know progressing whereas
another isn't just keep us all informed
as we go through thank you
there is absolutely no doubt that we
will do that counselor Junod in the
spirit of keeping you up to date there
will be a meeting of the leaders of
districts and boroughs this Friday so
without further ado I propose that we
accept the recommendations to cabinet
recommend to council exactly what I read
out
I'm councillor Pemberton is seconded
that so and can you take a vote please
but we start with you counselor
Jefferson or councillor Pemberton for
counselor Barker for having slaw Cargill
councillor Harvey for councillor Shenton
for you cancel really Hoggins for the
anonymous leader Thank You Anne so now
if you move on to the next item on the
agenda which is pavement licenses and in
the absence of councillor Perry I will
take this item this is an interesting
item in that each in anticipation of the
business and planning bill that's
progressing through the parliamentary
process which is likely to lead receive
Royal Assent before the next cabinet
meeting on the 27th of June sorry
27th of July this year can I just say
that this is all about hoping to give a
boost to the hospitality sector there is
a very tight time scale for turning
around the applications the pavement
licenses of the temporary measure
no license will extend beyond the 30th
of September and it's down to district
councillors to operate the scheme so
without further ado looking at the
recommendations on page 1
recommendations now that the exercise of
all the executives powers in relation to
pavement licenses pursuant to the
business and Planning Act 2020 is
delegated to the head of regulatory
services that the formulation of any
council policy for the administration of
pavement licenses be delegated to
regular people talia holder and the full
council be asked to milk the amendment
to the head of regulatory services
delegated powers set out in the council
scheme of delegation so sorry
commissioner has a question
all right council Shen to answer Shenton
here just a clarification on section 1.9
it says that the notice must be in place
for a consultation period of seven days
whereas the bill actually says five
working days now generally that doesn't
make a difference but if say somebody
applied during a bank holiday which is
August bank holiday coming up that could
make a difference the seven day or the
five day rule it's a bit a minor
clarification but it is not it does they
billed specifically just say five
working days thanks thank you for that
councillor Shenton mr. weeks would you
care to come in please
chairman thank you very much
I take councilor sentence point and I
think probably what we will have to do
for the for the is see what the bill
actually concludes see what the wording
of the bill when it becomes an act
actually actually confirms but in any
case what whatever the figure is and
whatever the arrangements are that will
be enshrined in the councils policy that
will come
all through the through the portfolio
holders delegated authority so whichever
one it is whichever process it is that
will be captured in the in the in the
policy document so the delegated
authorities will enable whatever is in
the act at the move change what's in the
bill at the moment to be coped with
corrects gentleman thank you are you
comfortable with that Chancellor Shenton
yeah as long as the as Robert week says
as long as the year the delegated
authority allows that yes perfectly
happy Thank You councillor Richard
Jewish to speak Thank You chairman I may
have misheard you or misinterpreted what
he said I think one of the
recommendations was that we delegate to
a portfolio holder my understanding is
we can't delegate with a portfolio that
as a cabinet but that would be for you
to do under your leaders statement is
that correct mr. Buckland can you
comment on that for me please
Ross chambers has said that is correct
what are the implications of that please
so the recommendations they changing do
they know I think I think leader you
might read from an old version of the
report all right sorry
um the up-to-date version of the report
just has two recommendations in that
case mr. chambers can you read out the
recommendations on the latest version of
the report for us please yes bear with
me so it's that the exercise of all the
executive powers in relation to pavement
licenses pursuant to the business and
planning at 2020 is delegated to the
head of regulatory services and that
full council be asked to note the
amendment to the head of regulatory
services delegated powers set out in the
council scheme of delegation
thank you are you content with that
counselor Richards I am yes I just yeah
I thought it best to bring to your
attention first Joan no thank you
so with those recommendations I'm
proposing we accept those
recommendations can I have a seconder
please
Thank You councillor Cargill so can we
move to a vote please on yes leader
councillor Jefferson for councillor
Pendleton or counselor Parker Council
I'll get a council whole body councillor
Harvey thank you beg your pardon muted
for Thank You councillor Center for
cancer really Hawkins for unanimous
leader
Thank You one so there be no further
business I'll declare the meeting closed
thank you everyone thank you